andrée est convaincu que sa nouvelle
conjointe julie et leurs bébés sont
couvert par son assurance fille mais
pour ne rien laisser au hasard
il en discute avec un conseiller en
assurance il a depuis cette assurance
alors qu'il vivait avec une autre femme
vita mais rita et lui se sont séparés
l'année suivante son conseiller regarde
ses papiers et il lui apprend alors une
bien mauvaise nouvelle
ce n'est ni julie lille bd qui pourront
profiter de son assurance sur c'est
plutôt son ex
rita pourquoi parce que quand il a
souscrit à l'assurance vie andré avait
désigné rita comme bénéficiaire
irrévocable le moule dit irrévocable
c'est définitif on ne peut pas revenir
là dessus résultat un délit ne pourra
pas faire profiter julie sa conjointe
actuelle leçon d'assurance vie à moins
que rita ni consentent péricaud non le
fin mot de l'histoire
l'avenir est déjà imprévisible alors
évitons de leurs envies révocable